you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 27
from the 1984-85 World Chess
Championship match between Karpov and
Kasparov this was the aborted match
aborted ultimately after 48 games and
prior to this game Karpov was really in
the driver's seat having won four games
to Kasparov zero and also worth
mentioning there were a string of 17
consecutive draws prior to this game 27
let's have a look and see what took
place in this game Karpov had white and
opened with the Knight f3 d5 by Kasparov
and we have a Queens gambit declined
keep in mind the style of both players
Karpov the more strategic Kasparov the
more dynamic tactical and that will
influence the decisions of course by
both players especially in the opening
after h6 we have Karpov investing the
bishop pair in exchange for what when we
look at the pawn structure we're going
to notice especially on the Kings side
that it's fairly static and there will
not be a great deal of dynamism in the
position or at least on the Kings side
what we will soon see take shape is
action on the Queen side but it will be
quickly resolved and we will essentially
be working with just half the chessboard
namely the Queen side of the board so
let's see that after e3 castles Queen c2
c5 this is as dynamic as this whole game
guess this is where there is the most
tension in the position but it's quickly
resolved after Queen a5 the Knights in a
pin castles and that earlier investment
of the bishop pair by Karpov is now
returned
we have Kasparov grabbing on c3 giving
up the bishop pair in exchange for what
well in this case in exchange for
damaging the white pawn structure after
97 this pawn plus it's not a very
healthy pawn but it's still a pawn plus
the pond plus that Karpov has will be
well it'll be restored the material will
be restored in this game and there's
some criteria we could really look into
in any chess game any position and now
is a good moment to look at that
criteria there's material there's space
time pawn structure and King safety all
big factors in the game which ones are
relevant in this game which ones are
relevant in this position if we look at
material we could essentially forget
about that because it will be restored
there's not going to be a way to rate to
defend this pawn material will not be
much of a factor space space does either
side have a pond positioned in one
another's territory no
so space will not be irrelevant if you
want it to be a little bit more pedantic
about the space factor you could maybe
say to yourself if you want to be a
little bit more technical about it you
could say or think is there is any one
of my pawns in a position to maybe be
placed in my opponents position and well
I don't really see that happening in
this position especially when there's no
Queens on the board that's usually much
more of a factor a space advantage is
usually much more of a factor if the
Queens are on the board and you're
looking to use that space advantage to
attack we're not really going to have
this great attack going on it's a much
more technical position time time is
actually a factor in this one because
white is already fully developed whereas
black not the case this Bishop still has
to move this Knight still has to move
before the bishop can move time will be
a factor there's also the pawn structure
well as it stands right now if white
makes let's say a rook to be one move
getting out a half-open file pawn the
pawn structure will actually be tipping
in blacks favor these are two perfectly
healthy pawns versus these that would be
tipping in black's favor and lastly we
have King safety that's not going to be
in
neither sides King is in trouble so well
if this is the one factor that's in
favor of white having a time advantage
maybe there's a way to give up a little
bit of that time maybe there's a way to
waste time in exchange for what in
exchange for damaging the white
extremely damaging the black pawn
structure that right there is maybe your
cue if you go through that list maybe
that's your cue to know that c6 would be
a very good move and was the move played
in this game what is it doing it's
investing some time in exchange for
damaging the black pawn structure and
we're still now in a position where
white maintains a slight time advantage
and that is the only factor that really
is showing up in this game and so the
big question will be how can Karpov put
to use the lead in time and maybe
convert that into a material plus so
let's see how things take shape we have
first the rook playing to an open file
might be sick gives the bishop a kick
and Bishop to e2 there's a whole sub
Bishop to b3 that might be one of those
knee-jerk type of reactions you back up
and you're still watching over these
knight moves but it doesn't address the
potential placement of this Bishop
Bishop a6 could be quite annoying and
this is a nice square that can maybe be
used by the black pieces so it's Bishop
to e2 staying on a closed file you don't
want to play to d3 because you're
accessible to a rook so you can still
just tuck yourself behind stay on a
closed file in other words and still
watch over a six and so the bishop as a
result is going to have to play to
either b7 or d7 soon enough we'll see
and play to b7 to take up a post on d5
and put pressure on a weak link the a2
pond so following up we have rook F 2 c1
may seem a little bit awkward this is an
open file and white is moving to a
closed file why exactly well it's an
anticipatory move anticipating what it's
anticipating Knight a for putting
on this pond and it's also vacating f1
because this king this is an endgame the
king wants to play an active role this
should be seven king f1 Bishop d5 and
now rook to b5 this pawn is immune from
capture well if it's captured initially
I thought well you take this pond you
could grab here but it's actually much
worse for black because this bishops now
quite short on squares it's only safe
squares to go back to the square came
from d5 but that can be interfered with
with c4 and after book b2 he's dead so
this is a poison pun in other words you
can't take on a to this pawn is the pond
thread is addressed with Knight d7 and
now we're up to a five this is a very
very active piece really can't act or
you really can't ask more of a piece
it's there to defend it's there to put
pressure on the to weak puns on blacks
Queen side so rook to b8 rook F to b8 c5
is there kicking the bishop from the
strong post and making sure that this
week pawn on c5 remains static its
mobile bishop c6 and now comes Knight to
e1 we see the idea here it's to put
pressure on the c5 pawn these are the
two pawns that are weak c5 and a7 it's
the c5 pawn however that is more
accessible to the white pieces so 91 the
intention is 93 and that pond will be
scooped up so Brooke to b4 is played for
what reason exactly after it should be 4
how does that interfere with Knight to
d3 this may very well steep still be a
good move but Karpov did not want to
allow this reply rook a for where the
black side would be able to exchange off
the very good white rook on a5 a follow
up could still be to essentially
replenish the rook replace that rook
that was on a5 by playing to C 3 a 3 but
there was just a more restrictive type
of move played at this moment right here
for this move 23 it wasn't 93 but first
a retreating move Bishop to d1
interfering with rooked
rook to a4 Karpov wants to keep this
very active rook on the board so now
comes anticipating Knight to d3 we have
the rook backing up staying on the
seventh rank and now f3 seems a little
bit curious why isn't Karpov running
right in 4th at c5 pawn let's take a
quick look at that if the knight runs in
too quickly we would have Bishop b4 yes
you went upon his white but now there's
a super active rook and may be yet
another that could enter the scene on
white's second rank this could be a
little bit annoying so it's a
restrictive move yet again just like
Bishop d1 preventing that rook to a four
move there's now f3 which is preventing
Bishop to e4 so now comes route to d8 in
comes 93 this pawn is hit twice defended
once it will be one soon how soon
exactly well first g5 we can you grab
some King side space maybe even get the
King up in this direction and we don't
have this capture right away this pond
is not going to go anywhere this pawn on
c5 and so first just getting another
piece involved getting the Bishop to b3
that would certainly rule out any
potential invasion on white second rank
with rook to b2 so Bishop to b3 it is
here comes King f8 and now Knight takes
pawn I thought I thought to myself at
this point just like Karpov played rook
or just like Karpov played Bishop to b3
at this moment improving one of the
pieces before capturing on c5 I thought
to myself why not do the same with the
king by playing to e2 but there's maybe
some tactical issue involved by having
the King on e too opposed to f1 and the
point I'm getting at is that after
something like rook to seat c7 maybe now
you're not able to grab that pawn so
easily right this would be tactically
flawed now since the bishop could now
make a move width check to the white
king
whereas if he just remains on f1 during
this capture on c5 when
waiking is still on this f1 square when
this capture happens there's not going
to be a bishop move you know to give
check to the white king so that's why we
have the immediate capture on c5 at this
moment instead of looking to improve
ever so slightly before this pawns
capture so it is Knight takes pawn
captures and then after that we have
what we have King to e2 just getting the
King more active rook d7 was played to
defend that bishop King to e7 just
getting the Kings active at this point
very technical phase white is up upon at
this point and still looking to convert
well so the rook back to that a5 square
now comes some more space gaining moves
getting these pawns rolling inching a
little bit closer hoping one day that
one of these pounds could be picked up
and then one of the black pawns will be
that much closer to queening so King
back he was only there to recapture the
rook on d1 so King e2 here comes more
space gaining moves and really what what
more can you do is black there's not a
way to improve the rook position or the
bishop position so it's just inching
these ponds a little bit closer to
queening again that's anticipating some
eventual capture down the road so h5 it
is and now this is an opportunity for
Karpov to strike at the black pawn
structure this is tying in well again
you really it's it's hard to imagine a
much more active position for this white
rook it's pressure here earlier had that
idea of defending a2 but now look at the
lateral movement in lateral influence it
has on the position this fifth rank so
II four ties in well with the rook on a
five takes takes rook is going to now
grab on that g5 square after that
sequence of moves and no side one
material Karpov didn't win material but
this rook remains still very active and
Bishop to f5 is now there to meet this
move this would not be a good idea for
white to be grabbing that ponceau Bishop
f5 defends this pawn in directly King e3
is now threat
to pick up this pond it's now moved and
now we're looking at King position
that's another factor we could kind of
look at as the position becomes more
simplified the Kings and what like to be
in the center this King is a slightly
more active than the black the black
hang on d6 so black interferes with this
gives the White King a kick he has to go
back to c3 this is the past pond this is
the one that white really would like to
get rolling but it's not so easy to
control that c5 square you can't get
this King to b4 and push that pawn so
easily so Bishop to b1 the pawn is hip
just play a3 getting out of harm's way
so that this Bishop is freed up to go
elsewhere if need be
now comes rook to e7 this pond is maybe
getting ready to roll rook to g4 attacks
this pond and we have h3 at this point
this pawn could be captured but Karpov
wants to keep this structure as is
playing g3 and maybe one day this pond
could be picked up keep in mind that if
this pond tries to run at this point if
black says you know what I'm I don't
care about my pond I'm just gonna start
pushing keep in mind that white would be
in time to play Bishop d1 III Bishop to
e2 and he's there just in the nick of
time to stop this pond from advancing
any further and there's now a
significant drawback by doing premature
pond advance like that namely it's the
d4 square you give that Square up and
you could be sure that the White King
will be making use of that nice central
dark post that d4 square soon enough so
if this pond in advance cannot be played
successfully right to its end you know
to a point where white would have to
give up the bishop then it's not
worthwhile to move it at all because of
the the big square that you would be
giving up to the white side again the d4
square so it is instead h3g three black
unfortunately has to just wait not a
good position to be in but rook to g7
hits this pond and now we have a little
bit of a race the car pops going after
the a pond black is going to now grab
that h2 pond and we do see that and now
keep in mind this pond is just two steps
away but that rook earlier when it was
on b7 what was it doing it was stopping
the King from making use of b4 so that
why key get this pond advancing so while
black goes after this pond here what is
white do white gets in a position to
finally advance this furthest advanced
past pond there's now two past ponds but
this is the one you really want to get
rolling especially since it could be
coming with tempo so rook takes pawn c5
comes we inconvenience that black king
with a couple checks and this pond
continues to march can it be tracked
down check King a5 the rook has to come
back c7 black is completely tied down
unfortunately at this point and it's not
going to be savable we have the bishop
there to watch over any potential
promotion on h1 if need be the rook can
maybe be playing over here to this h7
square not for right now since the
bishop is controlling it but if black
tries to let's say at this point
interfere okay the next move is this
this h2 move but after g4 if black tries
something like this to interfere with
the bishop
well now at least the rook is able to
come over here to track down the pond so
you would you would negate by playing
this efore move you would negate the
bishop from controlling
h1 but you're also interfering with the
bishop controlling h7 which allows for
h7 so we didn't have that after g4 is
played it was rook to h8 the rook plays
back to d1 hitting the bishop also
watching over h1 Bishop to a2 we have a
couple checks being thrown in again
which allows Karpov to pick up the e5
pawn the bishop is still there to watch
over h1 King takes an F Eric to e2 it is
at this point that Kasparov resigns
there's not a good reason
at this point what do you do the bishops
hit the pawn is hit the bishop moves
let's say here you just grab the pawn
fortunately this rook had two jobs it
was overloaded and you could grab on h23
capture we're just promoting with check
that's irrelevant the checking part but
that's pretty much what we would have
after it to eat till these guys are fork
the bishop move if the bishop were to
move with the game were to continue with
the bishop moving would just grab an h2
and that'll be game over so as it was in
this game after rook to e2 forking the
bishop in the pond
Kasparov is of course anticipating rook
takes pawn here there's no hope and he
ends up resigning so that's all for this
video if we actually take just a quick
look back usually I just cut out right
away but if we just review very quickly
this is a again touching on this early
point the strategic player Karpov versus
Kasparov going into a quiet variation if
you're a more strategic type of player
this might not be a bad line to employ
against let's say a dynamic opponent or
if you're a dynamic opponent maybe
there's something more you could be
doing instead of h6 or even entering
this type of opening the the queen's
gambit declined this specific variation
so we had that investment early on we
had some of the tension here with c5
it's resolved a very quiet position
investing what investing the bishop here
in exchange for damaging the white pawn
structure it is at this point I went
through what five things material
space-time pawn structure King safety
the big thing in this one currently was
pawn structure and the time white having
some time advantage here pawn structures
in blacks favor if white is not going to
do something about it making a move like
this again would allow a very healthy
pawn structure versus and not so healthy
pawn structure on the white side so
white invests some time in exchange for
damaging the black pawn structure now at
this point the biggest factor of those
of that list of five would be time and
eventually what did we see we saw that
converted quite nicely that
advantage was converted into a material
advantage and the material advantage was
eventually converted into a win so some
patients that some prep moves earlier
with the bishop retreating some prep
moves in other words with f3 eventually
that pond is picked up we work on the
king position and this rook is just
super active white remains up upon we
could look at the material at this point
we could also look at the I didn't point
this out in the initial pass but we can
look at the material factor of course
wiping up upon but also just the
activity level of both Brooks white
having the more active rook and
eventually as we saw this is converted a
slight race here after one another
obtains a passed pawn the C pawn versus
the a pond as it turns out the white
pond is going to be the more active one
and it was converted like so so again
this was right here the final position
after rook to e2 Kasparov ends up
resigning so that's all for this video
as always I hope you got something out
of it take care bye
you